[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans
checking in from the hot one set it is
so good to see your faces
and it's that time baby that's right out
with the old
in with the new it is time for the
season 13
official hot ones hot sauce reveal
and this season it is all about flavor
we are bigger and
bolder than we've ever been before going
from garlic to shawarma from middle
eastern spices to really pronounced west
indian flavors
to angry goats balsamic notes to
hellfire detroit's first
ever barrel-aged bourbon hot sauce that
has this kind of oaky taste
in season 13 we are swinging for the
fences when it comes to flavor
the biggest boldest flavor season we've
ever had
but it all starts with the familiar
friend the classic garlic fresno edition
in the lead-off spot
the blue label combines sweet and earthy
fresno chilies with 10 times the garlic
flavor of the original
it's a table sauce that goes with
everything it's just everything that you
want in that first wing sauce
and then at number two dawson's is back
with the shawarma sauce for season 13
our friends at dawson's created this
deep flavor sauce loaded with garlic and
spices
it has this rich olive oil base it is
almost too tasty there in the number two
spot
and then moving on to number three
shaquandas is back this time with the
west indian curry
everyone's favorite hot sauce queen is
back with a new caribbean classic
the recipe features fruity scotch bonnet
peppers and west indian spices
like ginger turmeric cinnamon thyme
allspice shaquanda's killing the game as
always and then at the number four spot
my favorite name of the season it is
angry goat pepper company's goat rider
a tangy blend of balsamic vinegar and
cayenne pepper is blended with roasted
red pepper and a big hit of vermont
maple syrup for sweetness
and then just a little kiss of ghost
pepper to give it that pop we like a
little pop here
on wing number four chris schoenberger
describes this sauce
as the country club salad dressing of
hot sauces
i don't know what that means but i'm
pretty sure i agree
all right moving on to number five you
know it you love it it's los calientes
rojo
rojo rojo you gotta roll that r
applewood smoked red jalapenos bring the
sweet
while a blast of citrus and a handful of
habaneros bring the heat
the perfect sauce for cruising through
grams all right
you know i missed it we got squeeze
bottle technology over here at number
six
the heartbeat crew is back for season 13
with the hottest sauce they've ever made
it's heartbeat hot sauces scorpion this
sauce is made with the trinidad scorpion
peppers so lots of heat up front
but then it's balanced out with lime
chipotle
beets gives it that delicate intricate
flavor profile that we've come to know
and expect from our friends at heartbeat
and then moving on to the seventh spot
hellfire detroit we are back and we are
booze infused
at number seven it's hellfire detroit's
bourbon habanero ghost and how about
this for a flavor profile
tangy apple cider vinegar oaky bourbon
fire roasted habaneros smoked ghost
peppers
it is the perfect dog leg for our back
nine
until you hit a wall here at number
eight
to bomb maintains its legacy position
i don't know how many years i've been
staring at the back of this bottle but
it's been quite a few
and i don't expect things to change
maybe someday they will
maybe someday they won't the bomb the
crafty old vet in our lineup that's been
here for years
and will likely be here for years to
come i have no plans to replace it
i do not want your angry fan mail please
i do not want the smoke i do not want
the smoke
the bomb maintains its spot in the eight
hole
but we have something very exciting
something new
here in the nine spot it's pucker butt
pepper companies
chipotle express you know pepper x from
the last dab
king of the hill since 2017 so what the
hell is it doing here in the nine spot
our friend smokin ed curry needed
another frankenstein project and here it
is
the chipotle express he uses his
infamous pepper
x but pairs it with chipotles lime
honey it has this intense building heat
that will make smoke come out of your
ears
and that leads us to the 10 spot i know
you've been eyeing it since the
beginning of the reveal
it is a brand new last dab everyone
please meet last dab
apollo with pepper x moving down to
number nine we have a new
highest peak at top mount scoville
introducing the last dab apollo
the only sauce in the world with the
apollo pepper
it is the newest most delicious but most
ferocious pepper yet from our favorite
mad scientist smoking ed curry and i'll
say this about the last dab apollo
it is by far the hottest last ab that
we've ever made i remember when we were
trying it out the first time chris
schoenberger just
tears coming down his face worried about
putting it on the show maybe it's too
hot for the show
maybe it's too hot for celebrities i
guess only time will tell
it'll be available first in the october
subscription box
and then more widely available later in
october
hot ones the last dab apollo mwah
welcome to the family look at that
beautiful gold label right there go
ahead punch in on that
one just a little bit give me one time
hit me one time putting pressure on
putting pressure on bill nailed it
and there you have it season 13
the hot ones hot sauce lineup and we
will be putting these bad boys to the
test
on october 1st that's right hot ones
rides again next week very short break
i missed your faces way too much we'll
see you next week hot ones fans
thank you thank you
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say
thank you so much for watching today's
video and join me
in welcoming the newest member of the
hot ones hot sauce family this is the
last dab
apollo the only sauce made with the
apollo pepper
the latest and greatest from the twisted
mind of smokin
ed curry it is the hottest last dab
we've ever made
and the people who will taste it first
are the subscription box subscribers
who will get this one in october's box
for everyone else
probably sometime later in october
heatness.com
heatness.com to learn more about the
last dab apollo
moment of silence for the last dab
triple x but it's okay
all new beginnings must come from some
other beginnings end